okay so two things one my voice is still
Oh Horace if you hear my IQ that's my
high pitch voice i voice is just by um
so I'm gonna move that lamp because it
just exposes all the more how bold I am
when my hair went up against it that's
much better
okay now it's more of an illusion um the
second thing is that we've decided that
whenever we do these I'm not going to
tell Rob what we're gonna talk about
just so we can always see his reaction
when I say well I want to do this always
wells know I'm always always but then I
can't think of funny quippy witty
thought oh no trust me you will with
this one Rob let's talk about Phantom of
the Opera let's talk about like the only
Broadway musical weaker up with
legitimately really liked knew the songs
knew the lyrics and everything and then
saw the guy who did the bad credit card
bring what we always imagined would be a
phenomenal film practically gif Rhett
film to us
so it would be wall above you both you
and Joel Schumacher oh my god no there's
actually a watcher to fucking hate this
movie well I know what's so funny I
don't like this movie I surprisingly
donate uh it's clearly not very good oh
so insufferable to get through here's
the thing
cuz we do grow up with this and I think
great growing up we used to say like it
was kind of like our fan fiction we'd be
like what if we did a movie like what
would it be how will be sure how would
we do this thing just shut up you're
making us sound like 12 no girl no cuz
this is our one okay this is like our
one that we did where we imagine is that
a movie is the mostly Moga theists of
all those yeah because we love Gothic
stuff we love great architecture we we
love Batman and like Honda mansions or
Twilight zones and stuff like that so
this was like really really cool and it
was just surrounded in
at UH the musical was just surrounded in
this great design and even people who
like didn't like the musical you know
say but the production was amazing you
know you look phenomenal
so eighties musicals were about you
didn't have to be a good musical you
said to put on a spectacle yeah that's
still kind of became I'll guess a Lion
King has a little bit of that um oh dude
Safina it's amazing the songs are still
shit you even be prepared they come out
and beyonds gonna sue yo ass uh but I
just was like half of you but okay we
have I grew up with one Broadway show
some kids they're not even listening
they're just typing away friend you son
of a bitch listen but know it started
with us saying we hate fan with the
Opera that was one half and now the
other happens like so no we really like
the music growing up even though we know
it doesn't always make sense and there's
tons of things wrong with it but the
stuff that really hit us just hit us so
strong it was so cool so when this movie
comes along as soon as we heard
Schumacher were like oh no that was me I
was just in it for Michael Crawford's
fall session and I saw the pictures
because this is before there wasn't that
much air in it yet I saw pictures at a
magazine and I thought it was the wrap
party I didn't think these were actual
pictures from nothing like cuz if you
see the phantom Gerard Butler of course
that's not the Phantom what are they
talking about the mask is like that big
he's this super good-looking build guy
and you know it's like that's clearly
not the Phantom and then I saw the
trailer and I'm and I'm like well
someone gonna look visually interesting
maybe it'll work and then they play just
a little snippet of him singing I'm like
that it just happened that did it just
happened um this is a good scene in Mars
Attacks a Joe Don Baker no no change
yeah but and happen we met more scenes
from botters a text that we do this and
oh just everything about the movie is so
amateurish that's what bothers me
like villain
and even I like trying to think of one
thing in particular so many it's like
the stupid hands the horse which I know
the horse was the book it still doesn't
make any sense
yeah the this Gerard Butler's singing
the makeup on him is terrible
the Vicky I'm not tripping over you're
right where's your the freaking
cinematography like it's a fucking
musical and I swear the camera never
moves is like it's too slowly pan around
and watch two people fucking stand there
and sing you know and even some nothing
is happening you look at something like
you know I I know we're not the biggest
fans about you hey move average more
than I do
I mean like it's alright but like you
watch something like Moulin Rouge and
it's just like there's kinetic energy a
shot moving yeah it's shot beautifully
it's just like it all of the tricks kind
of make you forget it's a stupid story
it's just like it's like not baby I know
I know you're talkative house but but
this one is just like they literally
it's just like Joel what he wants to
point the camera and you stand there and
sing like that's every fucking scene the
lighting is - for a movie that's
supposed to be like you know - dark
gothic the lighting is just terrible
you're a yellow throughout the whole but
not only you're in yellow but it's
literally like they just turned like
office lights on like it's that bright
washed out uninteresting it's like
you're stuck in a cubicle you know the
talk about you want harsh shadows in
this and everything are we this more
pink and um you're in yellow it's not
bright enough to be like wow that
visually is interesting it's not dark
enough to be visually interest at
horrible in between and you know with
something like lame is like even though
it's like a lot of simatai graffia it's
like okay a lot of these are really
close and it's kind of jumbled and stuff
we tunnel yeah we know what they're
going for at least it says postal or
gritties puzzle agree whether it fit you
know is kind of inaudible works it's not
even here is just they tried ya know
it's obvious they're trying to go for
the big sweeping spectacle musical and
but it's not done that way that Donnelly
respect to the song said like hey this
would be good for a whooshing shatter
this would be great for a crane shot or
close-up or whatever it's literally like
a TV movie like it's just shot like a
like a very expensive TV movie like you
just let's not do anything fancy just
let them talk do their thing and then
just the randomness of like some songs
they just start they drop some of the
lyrics they start speaking instead of
singing and I do that with why the
acting from just about everybody is just
it's just flatlined it's just like dead
on arrival the only thing I think the
only actor to actually Minnie Driver was
funny
okay I know I have to thought in
comparison to the others
Raul wasn't that bad uh because he
suffers the same problem that the
musical version did which is he's too
perfect he's too I'm your FOP yeah I'm a
a romance novel cover and stuff but but
you with that in mind I thought he
actually had a little bit literally good
okay
a yellow mop in a tuxedo and stuck it
there and it's the same thing and I did
you know what I will I will say this in
the film's defense the musical did kind
of the same thing yeah it's just my
opinion is aluminum or worse yeah you
could tell that basically Andrew Lloyd
Webber has a hard-on for the Phantom
that is like this is the Phantom story
and that the Phantom secretly I wish he
could win and then this is that that's
why for that horrible C cool III have
not seen even know that existed till
Beth mentioned it oh yeah but she was
describing the plot I'm like oh my god
is this irregular but so you can you can
tell he is like a hard-on for that
character the point Betty this is like
fuck Rowell like it's just like he's
just this bland Christine goes with
growl at the end but you could tell like
all the Webber's sympathies are with the
Phantom we you know and all the the fine
thing is that there's one of the reasons
I didn't dislike it as much as everybody
else even though I don't like it is that
um you know I'm thinking some things a
Schumacher usually does okay the one
thing he always does well even if the
some Tiger II is not that great he knows
how to show off the sense and when
there's a big huge cool-looking set he
does his best to show off the size of it
and how gigantic it is but then when you
put on there but underground yeah
underground where that supposed to be
giant and Matt Harding gothic yeah it's
just these little ways Iker like he's
rowing this boat it's like I feel you
could walk that where they do walk in
that wall run yeah later
it's like a it's like a fun house it's
like that Hall of Mirrors I'm here like
you know it it's like a bad fun house
you walk through like you want people
banging on the walls like boom boom boom
boom like it stopped playing um poor
shooting everything in bright yellows
and pinks by the way underground does
not make it scary well he said silly why
you know even the production of the
Phantom is very anemic differences
that's fine but the production of the
Phantom uh Broadway musical looks so
much nicer and grander more gothic and
blue and gray and so that when the red
came in it just leapt out of your red
death curve and it's all that blue and I
like that like outside of like the
little productions they do within the
show they're all like anything
surrounding the Phantom and and even
like the graveyard and the the rooftop
they're all like these kind of Van Gogh
blue tones offset by like yeah yellow of
candles and it's beautiful it's spooky
that's what it's fucking mystical the
Phantom of the Opera not - only right
hey um and you know some things they
moved around I was kind of okay with ia
I didn't mind the chandelier being moved
to the end I'm like okay climax that's
I'm not gonna care about that cuz ah
Matt Matt more sense they only did that
I think of the Broadway production cuz
you had to bring that chandelier back up
during the intermission I like 4/4 time
wise I like that they cut the second
note song which does not hold up as well
as I felt like even the musical I listen
to it again I'm like man this is not as
fast and clever as I thought it was
cause like when you're a kid you think
that you know that's just so quick and
cool in the lyrics and everything and
half the way
don't make sense that it's a little
slower so they cut the second one and
move it to the masquerade scene which I
thought that was kind of clever
um but aside from that and the way I
like the way they do the transformation
of the chandelier rising up at the
beginning and the flame coming in the
the little stage light and I thought
that was very effective that's like yes
that's what should have been done I
can't think of anything else that was
like that was a good move that was smart
that made this better you know and
honestly I thought the ending was
terrible I didn't need to see Raoul at
the graveside with the there's no point
there is no everything that'll give me a
mystery I don't want know what happens
after like what's already explained that
she's clearly dead you know I gotcha
knees this a dish in the musical it's
like a framing device to open in the
pass and we're all gets the fucking
stupid monkey I never really got what
was up with that monkey even in the
musical I'm just like that's great glad
you like the monkey christine like
spider monkey boo oh I can't do the high
pitch right now sorry but uh in the
movie there's just no point to it like
you I guess I guess I will say this in
the movie least with the intro it's cool
to see the Opera House come to life that
was one a few good scenes and the
chandelier falling was pretty cool um
but there's so many random thing that
the Phantom was like supposed to be
spooky like even in the book he like and
he was like Persian or something he had
like a magician sort of background he
was like a master illusionist he had
studied he had been around in carnivals
is like the freak show or whatever and
like in the musical it's like he shoots
like fireballs and the graveyard scene
there's a mad and in this one he's just
like it's a sword fight it's not even a
good sword fight it's a lame sword fight
and he gets bested and he's sitting
there on the ground like yeah jerks like
I'm like why am I scared of this guy
like I got he's a really pathetic fans
and phantoms already a little pathetic
yeah but his back seats like these from
a musical he was tried young and
released in the musical he was
mysterious
you know like always in the shadows
isn't it here he
- he just kind of has free reign almost
walk around anywhere I'm surprised that
more people spot him um you know and
what I see one of the scenes I thought
this is the most cinematic you know I
can't wait til someone makes a movie of
this and does something this is during
the ballerina scene before the guy is
faat before he's hanged you see the
shadow of the phantom like projected
onto the screen like looking around like
he's in front of a light and to threat
and it just it's so cool sees little
ballerinas and this giant shadow of the
phantom a you couldn't get more gothic
and operatic it's amazing don't do a
thing with you just seemed chasing that
guy kind of a silly saying are you going
to think or you own this week we go guy
I mean is it it's a it's like a
ridiculously comedic scene that then
ends with him being hung and I'm like
the fuck tonal shift like in the in the
musical at least it was more like it cuz
that area's high yeah it could have been
a fight you don't know what's going on
it could have been cold-blooded murder
here they just flat-out say it it's
cold-blooded murder well okay there goes
my sympathy like you're you're you're
still almost kind of wondering what's
going on up until he kills a PNG at the
end at that point you're like okay this
guy's just a fuckin insane psychopath
like now we've seen the evidence what an
I feel with bouquet you never quite knew
what was going on there here it's just
like he fucking chases that guy down
wraps a noose around is that could kicks
him off after this war one goofy scene
of them chasing around it just makes no
sense
I get a feeling like with the exception
again like maybe Marvel movies are a few
other films there's the sense that
everything has to be explained now in
movies and I think in sort of these
classic stories and and on Broadway and
a musicals and standard comic book films
not everything does and when you have
that mystery there it keeps it a little
open for you to fill in the blanks and I
think that's part of the fun is that
mystery in a lot of these great stories
and when they go out of their way to
show everything that's going on like oh
they never explained how we did the
fireball in the musical scream sound
fuck yeah it's like no no that's all so
we'll make it a sword fight it's like no
that's part of the fun is the illusion
how does he do have okay
how they do okay but here's but here's
what you don't - an illusion but here's
what tries me nuts it's inconsistent
because literally they're like oh we're
changing through sword fighting this
event and try to explain some of it or
cut out the mystical magical elements
but you got fucking candles rising from
yeah he got the moving on herbs like uh
like they did in the musical that turn
out magic II how the fuck did he do that
what's with all the hands like some
people like well Christine's dreaming
she's been drugged or whatever and what
where was that
uh I don't know there's like that's
everybody because later you see that
same hallway and there's no hands
anywhere so it's just like what's she
dreaming that was it a magic trick with
this like every time she's moving her
mouth how the time she's not yeah you're
throwing random shit in there so why
take out some of the other elements and
dumb them down with a god the fucking uh
the Punjabi lasso like where he just
like in the musical it's just like and
then I you could see be a fact because
the lighting at least when we saw wasn't
our eyes you can see the tiny string
holding it up but the idea is that it's
his lasso that's kind of almost
magically suspended here he's just like
here I'll hold still for a second but
and it's just like just like in times of
that cage or not after and shoving him
like literally just shoving him up
against like the cages I can't work or
I'm like this is Gary and it's like for
first off how did Ronald just not slip
out of that oh yes pretty we'll just
feeded this guy in a sword fight and all
of a sudden you're just sitting there
like well yes this is the air the water
was really cold it distracted him um no
and even in like the Broadway musical
because sometimes it's like a lasso
hanging by so sometimes it's just a
really really long rope that goes up
there sort of all these various ways
they do it but the idea is he's hanging
he's hanging from above and again
cinematically the angles you could get
with that you know the low shots a high
shot on what seat with a CGI you could
take the string out of it easily and it
would be a great effect ya know I mean
there's so many things you could do
ground this in reality even though we
had hands holding candles there even if
you don't do that effect there has to be
a way like you know in the musical he
sneaks up on us how he gets the rope
around do that sneaked up he gets the
rope as neck and then like I don't know
he hits a button or something and it
pulls him into the air there's he's an
illusionist he can do something just
cinematically isn't that so much more
interesting than just the three of them
just are standing there so awkwardly
and just kind of singing back and forth
I mean it's like it just you can spin
the camera around with all of them
singing and him hanging up there so many
things you could do and it just feels
like a million wasted opportunities on
something that's practically handed to
you saying make me awesome can we talk
about the casting too because the only
two that are perfectly cast are um
miranda Richardson and Minnie Driver
yeah the Brad's say they are the only
two that I think realize they're in junk
like I think they realize like oh this
is silly stupid we'll do whatever the
hell we want
and yeah so the two Brits come out just
they're hilarious
I actually like them but I think they
realize this is just fucking ridiculous
um but you know the Rowell didn't leave
much of an impression I know
Rahl's supposed to be I think they were
childhood friends but I still feel like
even then he looks like he's ten yeah he
looks like he's he watches she's super
yawn too um he carries himself much more
like a fifteen year old than like I felt
like somebody's really supposed to like
take Christine and be like babe I'm here
to protect you no more worries you know
dry your tears isn't that I just I
wasn't feeling the confidence problem
because the voice like this you might
have like it's very Leonardo to care it
might be a psych class in the x-men
movies it's like okay you're not like
bad or anything but you're not that's
like yeah I believe the original realm
from the London cast recording this he
had like kind of this deeper voice yeah
yeah I mean was and it's like I'm
everyone it's yeah and I mean good ones
they actually
older like and he's probably everybody
was wait for seventies yep sarah
brightman she clearly wasn't sixty yeah
you know but it is at least a voice
carried it so I'm like okay I believe
this guy V this is like I will fucking
protect you
yeah like I just went this kid is just
like you know these he's not terrible
but it's just like you know them all
talk of time like I just I'm like Kim
can I hire a bodyguard then though we
still best the Phantom somehow we listen
to the interesting thought because they
were talking when they're talking about
casting it the big thing wasn't olya
maderas he's gonna be the Phantom and
neither of us thought she was like a
great singer like the perfect again he
was too sexy you can't get a guy til
sexy dull sexy like the SNL sketch uh
but you can't get a guy who's like a
sexy phantom like visually it's more
psychologically it's like Dracula though
he said Dracula sometimes can be
visually sexy but it's very much the
psychology of power yeah the power
struggle in control uh you know so but
Antonio could do that but he was just
way too good-looking you said you're a
good idea you say he should have been
rolled yeah though this really cool like
she would have been decades you would
have had a guy that was legitimately
younger like yeah you could do it but
yeah the school again that would be a
cool Raul Almeria
yeah like the the early days you mean oh
yeah um but yeah cuz like he has the
confident that's my problem like most
roles they just kind of they suck any
sort of masculinity out of them by
almost being too masculine in a weird
way I but uh do what you like only free
uh I mean it's like and same thing in
free her to what you guys got the long
hair just are fine they're just trying
too hard this casting and it I feel like
if you're going to create a counterpoint
to the Phantom I feel like there's been
this misjudgment that oh well you have
to get somebody who is so light and airy
and the opposite and I'm like uh
necessarily buy that like I think you
could have two guys that are more
equally matched you know it's just one's
a psychopath and one actually cares
about it but I always look particularly
in the new school I look like quite does
she go with Raul I mean
I'm like the Phantom so much more
interesting and it's clear that was
Andrew Lloyd Webber's you know take on
I'd like to keep did that on purpose but
it it does bother me because I feel like
this should be more of a no contest and
the decision should make sense and in
the end I'm just like you know maybe if
you just didn't kill a guy or two he may
have been happy with this baby fare
that's kind of a big you know but I mean
there's no company no competition
otherwise I feel like there should be
real competition if you're gonna do a
love triangle yeah I mean he does that
he does the long song the all I ask of
you this all I get it's like okay like
yeah and I think it's it's a kind of it
I mean coming in any other cars and of
course he just basically puts her out
there as bait like Inc so I I don't know
but it so I feel like Rao's miscast I
Christine I I'll get help for this the
voice is fine I don't have a problem
with the voice it's the wrong voice
though it's I have a problem with the
voice I don't like the voice it's a nice
thing it is with we it yes
it's weak it's not like an an opera it
doesn't have that sort of operatic
quality that if you need for this role
it's the singer to say okay I mean
that's not an awful voice you can see
here I it sound nice but it's not like
I'm getting money to see this person
like whoa this is like move over other
opera stars this one is some real
competition and on top of that and I'm
not saying Sarah Brightman and her
machine gun vibrato and that isn't like
doesn't have its own sort of what it is
but yeah it has the strain is like same
scene for me I'm like alright bring down
the house right now and says it's ain't
same thing with a Crawford is that you
know we make fun of his voice all the
time still silly but it's got its its
its own weird thing that kind of work
yeah its its own strange power it's like
it's a punch and it's heavy and it's
like he can sing he clearly can't he is
a goofy as it is like it's a little
silly yeah like you get why this guy
would be you're both they're both kind
of different like which i think is part
of the point that's one thing I do like
about the music I was part of the point
is they were both doing kind of
different things whereas the Opera was
stuck in its own like just doing the
same old same old
um but that her acting too
I'll say this about sarah brightman she
and this I think was the key to part of
the musical success she looks like a
woman who is being haunted scheduled
yeah crazy
doughy scary eyes then just lay it at
that because I have been mild yeah it
looks like she's been like like she's
being hypnotized possessor like she some
walking goes this woman just she just I
don't know it she just she smiles all
the time she's just like I'm like you
don't look that put out by anything like
I'm like I just don't believe like and
she's like oh well I'm scared I don't
believe it
like when Sarah Brightman says I was
like I I think you believe this guy's an
actual ghost I think you're out of it
like that's thing about Sarah
Brightman's version of it you couldn't
tell if she was just some sort of goofy
silly girl or if she was out of her
fucking mind
yeah like she was a play and he put in
the phantom always played on that like
this girl's cuckoo for cocoa puffs I can
work with this yeah I never I never got
that that's what I want in the movie I
just that's why I was good at Christine
is that the Phantom is very much playing
it as she's been through this hard
ordeal she's clearly not all there and
you know he's telev anted and he's
playing with her psyche she's got daddy
issues yeah her father's death clearly
left her nuts and obviously the Phantom
who is this older guy who comes in
basically trying to move in as like a
surrogate father slash lover slash
teacher thing I mean it's it for what it
is this like pot boy was story it's a
really creepy story nothing really came
out in the movie all that much like cuz
she's just she's always smiling and like
just doesn't and I'm daddy bottom and
then Gerard fucking Butler but there's
one other thing I'll say about uh
brightman comparison to the movie is
that when she said something saying
something I should say when she's saying
something it sound like she was saying
something when the other actress is
singing it just sounds like she's
singing you know in the other musical
they were singing but they were saying
something where everyone in this musical
it just sounds like they're just singing
well now so song we're gonna sing a song
we're not telling you the story they
don't sing it like we're telling this
story we're telling you what we're
feeling right now and that to be within
that portrayal of Christina was the key
to the Lloyd Webber musical I love the
weeks of the key the key the key
don't go oh I got woken up I get it and
it just I
you got me off track yeah let's talk
about Bob where um first up is a as a
person like I think juror but was
hilarious and I have no like this is
like I like follow him to hell and back
I did hundred yes amazing in that movie
I'm not even talking about sarcastic or
anything he legitimately has some
incredible as goofy as a movie is some
incredible leadership skills in that
role you know certainly as ready to
follow is a Spartan and the thing is
like when he's in the right role I think
he's amazing is there's no Gerard Butler
hitters like know it but this plenty of
celebrities are legitimate we just don't
like like he's not one of them it is
just the most hotly
Lloyd Webber the casting director
Schumacher shame on you for doing that
to Gerard Butler somebody I legitimately
like because he is so fuckin miscast in
this role it's oh my god the singing is
awful
is the the makeup on him the fucking
sunburn or whatever on his face it it's
clear that I don't think he knew what to
do when it came to the acting and I'm
not saying as a bad actors as well as
where it's like I doubt the direction he
was getting without a fight yeah um just
somebody who had no business to be
casted head oh yeah not much there's not
much else I can even say except for that
like Crawford is silly as this at least
played it off as this hypnotizing spooky
like that's a thing he's like a Scooby
like the Crawford versus like a
scooby-doo joke like oh yeah I eat that
owned it though he's hauled in lately
all in it and that's in the musical with
its dark lighting and the you know the
spooky mist and all that it worked it
fit just Gerard Butler plays it off like
he's fucking Laertes just like you're
turn founder and I'm just like it
doesn't work it's even whispers he's
kind of yelling
I am your eyes um yeah no the table bad
- I am for a lot of the actors Andreea
Serban like this I feel like they're
just hashed into a movie yeah they were
pushed into a movie that's like well
it's the Phantom it's gotta be it they
say I can sing I mean what why would you
think you could sing if everybody says
you can say it's pushing a square piece
into a round peg and they're like
beating it down like no way we'll make
this work like pretty much nearly all
the casting um I can't
cha there's anything else yeah I just in
you know what bothers it's like okay
we're going on oh the musical this
musical dead and and I've often said
that's like no you can change things
it's about adapting so much changes are
good um but here's my thing even if I
didn't see the musical I would not think
this is a good movie on it no it
wouldn't suck me and because it
interests bad it is and that's what
bothers me like the people who defend
this um I get it the Phantom's dreamy
rounds dreamy or you like you like all
the little hands and the candles and she
rides a pony and whatever whatever don't
try to tell me though that this is good
filmmaking because literally from a
technical perspective this is terrible
filmmaking it's bad cinematography it's
it's only decent choreography at best
the narratives a mess
the lighting is terrible like it's
community college type stuff it is that
is not good filmmaking so don't try to
have your disciple I like the movie go
ahead like the movie I don't care that's
fine but don't be like but it's a
legitimately well-made film it's not
says some shots boy on rouges yes in
some shots you know one or two of them
are frame knives like I said especially
in the opening and stuff but even even
watching it again I remember I first saw
it I thought the simatai graffia was
more interesting back then uh because
some of these trees were being used as
much as we were just discovering them
now years later it's like I'm watching
if I might remember suddenly shot I
thought were much more impressive
back then and they just look so standard
now it's like when we rewatched the
passion I am we were outside the brat
about like you know I groom
you remember this looking a lot better
yeah really yeah not just cow looks like
a hallmark religious Channel movie you
know it just doesn't look as grand as it
did back then and I think that is
something to just there's some you need
someone that's just like hey not only is
this gonna look good but you know the
focus is gonna really really draw you
it's gonna pop out and grab you and
that's the kind of summit ography that
really holds up speaking of brad we were
just talking I I think it pertains to
this you want an example of a bad movie
that is technically made really well a
technical level Exorcist - that's
terrible movie but on a technical level
the the cinematography the production
design everything it's a fascinating
movie to watch it's yeah mate it looks
like a Kubrick film is unbelievably
dreamlike this in my opinion if you want
to argue all ooh think it's gonna be
fine in my opinion this is a bad movie
but what you can't argue is that it's a
technically well-made film even on a
technical level it's shot and I expected
more from Joel Schumacher cuz I'm a
technical level at least bamming of
Robin I thought those sets were kind of
whoa I mean well KITT I've seen Joel she
doesn't look like Batman bail-ins cool
I've seen Schumacher put together
better-looking films yes so it's like
vizima just too much the masquerade some
of the shots of masquerade are okay and
one of the youngest and all the good
shots are there all the chandelier
yeah I think it's the chandelier rising
up I like the chandelier fall sparkly
and fabulous just like me I want to make
the movie only about the chandelier
sister-sister you making some for in
there is it he's just always a bubbly
guy after everyone says it's so romantic
jealous I was there oh man you know it
it's cuz in my head I always get him in
like yonder bond I can say they look
alike
throw them into the same category of
like they should all have a vague axe I
always do really bare riffing of the
Schumacher kiss every touch it's like
ripping - Gary Marshall
every time I see an interview with this
person he seems so sweet and so nice and
I'm sure he is I'm sure you know I don't
have a brown ripping into Lloyd Webber
yeah he's an asshole yeah like I was
like what I will say in Schumacher's
defense we you never know when a movies
being made how much maybe Schumacher's
just was doing this for a paycheck and
or how much she's like baby I should do
this way and Lloyd Webber was like no
because he had an iron grip on a movie I
feel like he he seems like a guy who
doesn't fight like if the studio says
change this would be like well okay and
maybe he'll put up a little bit of a
fuss but he seems like he's such a nice
guy again I don't know this is
speculation let the studio take over
something and they just want something
safe and he is super safe he's a super
safe director but it's also not very
interesting or very good it may be the
nail in the coffin for me over what to
make of Joel Schumacher this movie just
cuz I I feel like he kind of peaked
early on decent films and then just it's
gotten increasingly worse and I I don't
know I will say this in his in defense
when it comes to him directing this film
he's done better so I'm not it's not
about Joel Schumacher ages egg because
I'm just like he's done way better than
this movie I enjoy falling down like
that yeah I fucking love their movie um
I as you thought Batman Forever was a
decently directed film um in really
maybe we did a whole riff on that movie
I won't compare to Batman and Robin okay
but I you think affair to Ben honestly
you know okay I know it's just anything
he is not a we make fun of baman forever
but the studio notes were Jesus Christ
Batman Returns was in our rating
practically and everybody hates us for
it lighten this fucker up again what do
I feel I feel I wanted to do we had to
do a good job in this kitchen home into
that so you know now Bevan Rowan I'm
gonna defend but they'll still the
production design was interesting it was
more interesting than with some agree he
can direct
fine like the clients fine uh what time
the keel is fine
lost boy if I haven't seen it here is
really good as I hear that
very very good so it's not like oh yeah
I think he touches garbage it's like
Nollan now Lloyd Webber who basically
was not doing movie musicals for so long
he's like he'll never be exactly as my
vision comes out with this thing
and this is like finally the way I want
like now I can I can't defend that and I
here's a bit of a prick anyway yes I'm
not gonna lose sleep on him wait you
just watch him on video like whenever
he's with Sarah Brightman it's just this
competition of who can make the other
feel more uncomfortable good there there
divorce was a messy divorce apparently
like and everything to just tell what
you're fucking just like once just like
sir poking like them beer I'm gonna poke
you back I'm gonna poke you but I'm not
gonna flinch I said you know cath you
bet yeah I said your house I'm fine
and we're just doing the smile and stuff
and it's like wow this is like and but
at the end though just finally but he's
not part of it he's on the part of the
House of Lords or something like shows
up at a fur coat that's how bad I like
that he looks like a yeah got me Phantom
of the Opera um so yeah but I don't know
what else to say about the zom-- just
men's disappointment for me yeah I mean
oh no well we maybe the reason I didn't
hate it as much as cuz I lowered it so
much
knowing Schumacher was directing it I
had such Batman and Robin hey see when I
hurt you know I was directing it I was
so worried but I thought well at least
the production design will be good and I
was kind of horrified at how you could
see the Schumacher touches here and
there but it just really wasn't even
that interesting I'm like why I expected
even more and the one thing that should
have been dark cuz I I thought Batman
Forever like he kind of had a grasp on
how to get some awesome stuff and the
undergrad someone they got not well
he'll be able to do that is you know
experience directing in the Batcave I'm
fuckin fuckin lights and I frickin pink
and like it looks like an underground
grotto for a ten-year-old girl weapons
and I think the theories I didn't
dislike it as much is because honestly I
just always wanted to see a phantom
movie and it's like okay summit wish I
got one yeah well some of this stuff I
find
he did see on the big screen like I said
all the chandelier stuff was very cool
once in a while working in the shadows
was oh it's so it's exactly like the
musical what do you think chandelier was
cool yeah pretty much everybody so nice
on happy burger no musical uh so yeah
that's why they can't think of much else
uh um all I can say is Funko damn it I
can't don't you do it I can't get that
high yeah let's just end with the
falsetto whoo so be it